[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So I have to admit this
is extremely awkward,
lecturing to an empty room.
So I have to imagine
there's somebody
on the other end actually
listening to me at some point.
Perhaps this is what YouTube
stars have to go through
at some point in their career.
So what is the purpose
of this course?
So this is for 18
100A, Real Analysis.
So the purpose of this
course is twofold.
Really, I think the first
primary purpose of this course
is to gain experience
with proofs.
So that means being
able to read a proof,
being able to write a proof.
And the second statement,
or the second purpose,
which is supposed to be a way
to obtain the first purpose,
is to prove statements about
real numbers, functions,
and limits.
OK.
So the second part, this
is the analysis part, OK?
So for the first
few lectures, we're
going to do what maybe to
some will be kind of review.
And for most of you,
a lot of this material
in the first few
lectures will be review.
But it's a nice way to
ease into the material.
And things will most definitely
pick up after a few lectures.
So the first set
of objects we're
going to define and try to prove
some statements about are sets.
So definition-- and because
I use a lot of shorthand,
I will mostly write
Dfn from now on instead
of the entire word, definition.
So a set is a
collection of objects
called elements or members, OK?
Now, this course
is supposed to be
probably the first really
rigorous course in math
that many of you will deal with.
So essentially, everything
that we talk about
will be rigorously and
unambiguously defined.
But we do have to
start somewhere.
And so maybe you
think this word,
"collection," is a
little ambiguous.
And perhaps you should.
But to actually build up set
theory from the ground up
would take us quite beyond the
scope of this class and too far
afield of the things
that we want to do,
or at least that
what I want to do.
OK, so a set is just a
collection of objects
called elements, or members.
There is the simplest
set to define:
the empty set is the
set with no elements.
And we denote it by this symbol
here-- a circle with a dash
through it.
OK, so with new math
typically comes new notation,
new symbols that you use.
So let me introduce a few
shorthand notations we'll
use throughout the course.
I mean, quite honestly,
this is a little bit
of the fun of doing higher math.
You get all these funny symbols.
And a very accomplished
mathematician
at the University
of Chicago, one time
said, you're really only
interested in the math
where that has the
symbols you like
to write over and over again.
So some notation--
a and this symbol
which this symbol,
which looks like a e-S
means a is an element
of S. A with a dash
through this little e
means everything here but.
So a is not an element of S.
This upside down
A means for all.
It's shorthand for all.
Backwards E means there exists.
And a couple of more--
if you see an arrow like
this, this means implies.
So I've written down one thing.
This implies the next statement.
I'll put an arrow between them.
And an arrow going both
ways means if and only
if, meaning if I have a
statement P if and only if Q,
that means statement P implies
Q and statement Q implies
P, all right?
And if you need a quick
refresher on basic logic,
you can find that in the
appendix of the textbook.
OK, so that's the basic
definition of set, empty set.
So set A-- another
definition to set
A is subset of B, which we
write A, this little symbol
that looks like a C, B
If every element in A
is an element in B.
Little a's in capital A
means little a is in capital B.
So two sets are equal--
we write A equals B--
if A is a subset of B
and B is a subset of A.
And A is a proper subset
of B if A is a subset of B
and A does not equal
B. And we typically
write that by A and
with a dash going
through a line underneath the C
to signify that it's not equal.
So think of it as not,
so less than or equal to,
but not equal to is one
way to think about it.
OK, so let me say
something since I'm now
1, 2, 3 definitions in.
So definitions are a fact of
life when it comes to math.
In the beginning of
any subject, there's
going to be a lot of definitions
because we have to have objects
we want to talk about.
And we have to have these
unambiguously defined objects.
So it may seem
like there's going
to be a lot of definitions
now, but this will let up.
And we will start proving
some theorems, which
are facts, about these objects.
These are the things
that we're really after.
We're not really after
just making up definitions.
Definitions are meant
to be a rigorous way
of defining an object we're
interested in studying.
We're interested in proving
theorems, facts about them.
So again, a lot of this
is just probably review.
When we describe sets,
we will use these braces
and maybe list the
elements in here.
Or we will describe
it as x in some set A,
satisfying some property P of x.
Or we won't write
this x and A part.
We'll just write all
objects x satisfying
x, as being an element of
whatever universe we're in,
that satisfy
property P of x, OK?
So again, you should read this
as all satisfying property
P of x.
So the basic examples--
and this is-- you
should expect this
after seeing any
non-trivial definition.
If you were here, I would
ask you to call me out,
so I'll have to police myself.
But after every
semi-interesting definition,
you should see examples, OK?
This is how you actually
learn about these things,
or at least digest
what these things are.
So we have the
natural numbers, which
everyone is familiar with
since they started to count--
1, 2, 3, 4, and so on.
We have the integers, which
is 0, 1, minus 1, 2, minus 2.
So all the natural
numbers, along
with their additive inverses,
along with the 0 element,
an additive identity, we
have the rational numbers.
So this is written as m over n
such that m and n are integers
and n does not equal to 0.
And we have R, the real numbers,
which I, as of right now,
cannot actually write down
what they are in terms
of set-building notation.
In fact, this will be our
first goal of the course,
is to give a proper description
or definition of what
R actually is.
But you can think of this
as you did in calculus,
as Q along with--
so rationals and irrationals,
like pi and 2 and these things.
So this is fine to
think about for now.
So of course, I didn't
have to use these.
Maybe I'm interested
in odd numbers.
That's a set of numbers
of the form 2m minus 1,
where m is a natural number.
So this is just 1,
3, 5, and so on, OK?
And so note that we
have the inclusions.
Natural numbers are contained
in the integers, which
are contained in the rational
numbers, which are contained
in the real numbers, OK?
And if you look at the history
of why these things were
thought up in the
first place, I mean,
they were thought up to
solve polynomial equations
that you couldn't solve in
the number system before.
Integers were created
because I could not
solve the equation
x plus 1 equals
0 in the natural numbers.
Rationals were thought
of because I could not
solve the equation 2x plus
1 equals 0 in the integers.
And the real numbers were
thought of because I cannot
solve the equation x
squared minus 2 equals 0
in the rational numbers.
Now, I can't solve the equation
x squared plus 1 equals 0
in the real numbers,
which led to the creation
of complex numbers.
But we will not deal with
complex numbers in this class.
Although hopefully, if you
keep studying analysis,
you go on to complex
analysis, which
is really a beautiful
subject of study to this day.
So as I said--
let me write this here--
our first goal, real goal
of the class-- and this
is something to keep in mind.
We're not going to
do it right now.
Our first real goal is to
describe what R is, OK?
I mean, if we're going to
be proving statements about
the real numbers, functions
of real numbers, and limits,
whatever-- those limits that
you learned in calculus--
then we have to be
able to really describe
what we're starting
with, the real numbers.
OK, so let's get back to
sets, to our review of sets.
So there were some examples.
We have a few more definitions.
The union of two sets, A and
B, is the set which we write--
so this is how we
denote it, A U B. This
is the set of all elements x.
x is in A or x is in B.
The intersection of A and B--
so this was defining the union.
This was defining
the intersection--
is the set A cap B. And
this is a set of all
x's so that x is
in A and x is in B.
So the union is take
all the things from A,
take all the things from
B, and put them together
in one big basket.
The intersection is
just take the things
that A and B have in common.
The set difference of
A with respect to B
is the set A
backslash B. This is
the set of all
elements in A such
that x is not in B. The
complement of A is the set A--
so this is how I'm
denoting the set.
The next part is how
I'm defining the set.
This is a set of all elements in
our universe that is not in A.
And when I say universe, I don't
mean this universe necessarily.
I mean, if we're
looking at subsets of R,
the complement is generally
with respect to R.
Or if all of our sets
are subsets of Q,
then our universe would
be Q, the rationals.
And we're taking the
complement in there.
Two sets are disjoint if their
intersection is empty, OK?
So it took me quite a
long time to figure out
this compliment has an E in
the middle as opposed to an I,
as in the compliment
you would give a friend.
I had to do a lot of
spell-checking in my thesis
when my advisor
pointed that out.
So this is just something
to keep in mind.
This complement has an
E in the middle of it.
OK, so let me just
draw a quick picture.
So this blob over
here is A. This
is a set B. This is a
set C. In fact, let's
make this a little more--
OK, let's keep C there.
Then what I have here, that's
A intersect B. This bit
over here, with the
lines going this way
but not including this, this is
A take away B, A backslash B.
And OK, so that
was not meant to be
along the same direction as
this one, so let's go vertical.
And everything with a vertical
line is A intersect B, OK?
So A backslash has the
lines going this direction.
A intersect has the lines
going this direction.
A union B has the
lines going vertical.
And C is way over here not
touching any of A and B.
So A and C are disjoint
and B and C are disjoint.
OK, they have nothing in common.
OK, so this was a
lot of definitions.
We have not proven a
single statement yet,
so it's about time we do.
This is probably one of
the most basic theorems
one can prove at the start
of a Real Analysis class
or any class about proofs.
This is analogous to when you
write your first Hello World
program in a programming class.
So let me state the theorem,
which is DeMorgan's Laws.
And the statement
is the following.
So if A, B, C are sets, then I
have several things I can say.
The union of B and C,
taking their complement,
this is the intersection
of the complements.
So the complement of the
union is the intersection
of the compliments.
If I take their intersection
and take the complement,
this is the union
of the complements.
So the complement
of the intersection
is the union of the complements.
Now, these are complements,
meaning I am, in some sense,
taking a set difference with
respect to the entire universe.
But I can make these things
relative to some set A.
So A take away B union
C, this is the same
as A take away B intersect A
take away C. Really, again,
you should think of this
as a special case of one.
Or at least if you were
to write the proof--
I'm not going to
because it's all
going to be contained
in the first two--
then you would see it's really
just a proof of this guy.
A take away B intersects C
equals A take away B union A
take away C, OK?
So again, for a quick
refresher about logic
I would look at the
appendix of the textbook.
In general, so let
me make a few remarks
before we move on to the
proof about typically
how this is going to look.
So this is some remarks.
Typically, a theorem
is a statement
of the type P implies Q. Let
me write this out in English.
If some statement
P holds, then Q--
for us, it's if I
have any three sets,
then I have these equalities
between these operations
of sets.
So the general structure
you'll see of the class
is I have objects which
I define unambiguously.
I want to prove theorems
now, meaning true statements
about these objects.
And the real meat
is the proof part.
So what is in this
mysterious guy, the proof?
It's quite simple.
You start with-- you assume P,
meaning what you were given,
the hypotheses, the
hypothesis, P, and--
I'm going to put dots here--
through logic and most
definitely, most of the
time some calculations,
you arrive at Q is true.
And most proofs are ended
with this little box here, OK?
So most proofs have
this structure.
I take my hypotheses.
And these hypotheses
mean something
in terms of the
definitions I have given.
And now, I need to use these
unambiguous definitions,
along with logic and
maybe some calculations,
to conclude that
statement Q is true.
That is the essence of a proof.
That is all there is to it.
Now, that doesn't mean
it's a simple thing
to learn how to do.
That's the point of this course.
But distilled down, that's
what a proof is, OK?
And Q-- so I said P usually
means something in terms
of the definitions we have.
But also, Q will usually mean
something in the definitions
that we've given.
And so our job is to
verify Q. So let's
go with proving this theorem.
And in fact, I'm only
going to prove property 1.
Property 2, 3, and 4 I'll
likely put on the homework.
So let B and C be sets.
So I mean, this is the
only hypothesis I get.
I'm trying to prove
that B union C
complement equals
the intersection
of the complements.
So what does that mean?
So we want to prove.
So this is-- it's quite
helpful, especially
when you're first
starting to do proofs,
to write down what you're
actually trying to prove.
So even though I have
this statement here,
it's an equality
between two sets.
Equality between two sets means
something specifically, right?
We have that in our definition--
where is it-- over
there that two sets
are equal if one is a subset
of the other and vice versa.
So that's what we have to prove.
We have to prove that the left
side, B union C complement,
is a subset of B complement
intersect C complement and vice
versa.
So we want to prove that
is a subset of B and--
OK?
So that's what the
equality means.
That's what we have to prove.
We have to prove those
two statements now, OK?
And that's as distilled
down as far as we can go.
So let's prove this.
Now, we'll prove this
using, again, logic and what
these things actually are.
So let's prove this
first statement here.
So I have to show that
every element in this set
is an element of this set.
So I'll even write
this down as WTS.
That means Want To Show.
This is the first
thing we'll show.
As we go on, I'm
not going to write
as much as I'm doing right now.
But this is the first theorem
and proof you're seeing,
so I should write
down quite a bit.
So the first thing
we want to show
is we have this inclusion, OK?
That means every element
here is an element here.
So let x be in B
union C complement.
And now, we're going to
trace what this means.
And we'll eventually
arrive at x as in this.
So then x is not in B
union C. That's just
the definition of
the complement.
Now, x is not in B union C means
x is not in B and x is not in C
because the union is--
something's in the
union if it's in B or C.
So something's not in the union
if it's not in B and not in C.
Now, this implies, simply
again by the definition
of what it means to
be in the complement,
x is in B complement and
x is in C complement.
But this, again, is
simply the definition
of x being in B complement
intersect C complement, OK?
So you see, we started off
with an element in this guy
and we showed that it's also an
element of the right-hand side.
So thus, B union C complement
is contained in B complement
intersect C complement.
Now, we want to do this
other inclusion here.
Now, this is one of those
rare situations where
you get to essentially
reverse the entire argument
and get what you want.
But let's just go through
it in a linear fashion.
Let's take something from
here and show it's in here.
So let x be in the intersection
of the complements.
Then that means x
is in B complement
and x is in C complement.
That means x is not in B--
so that's this statement.
That's the definition of
being in the complement--
and x is not in
C. That's, again,
the definition of being
in the complement.
Now, just like we used
here in this step,
this is equivalent to--
so really, I should--
in this statement, I
should have written
this statement is equivalent
to this statement,
but we'll remove that.
So x is not in B
and x is not in C.
This means x is not
in their union, which
implies that x is in the
complement of the union, OK?
So thus, we've proven
is a subset of B.
And since we've
shown both sets are
a subset of each
other, that means,
by the definition of two sets
being equal, they are equal.
Again, this box
means really nothing.
It just means that's
the end of the proof.
All right, let's move over here.
This is terrible.
And not everybody uses that
little box to finish a proof.
Some people don't put anything.
When I was in
graduate school, I was
a TA for this guy
named Paul Sally who
was a fantastic teacher
and really loved math,
who would end--
So amazing story about this
guy is, when I was his TA,
he was in his 70s, I think.
But he had also had diabetes.
So he had lost both of his
legs beneath his knees.
He was also legally blind.
And he had a patch over one eye.
So he himself often
referred to himself
as the a pirate mathematician.
But he would end
his proofs with--
at least in his
textbook-- he didn't
ask me to do this on
the board, thankfully.
He would end his proofs
with a picture of himself
with this cob pipe
that he had, very much
in the pirate fashion.
Anyways, OK, moving on from
things that end proofs,
let's go on to a next
subject, induction.
So induction is a way to prove
theorems about natural numbers,
OK?
The theorem itself is
more of a tool rather
than an interesting
fact on its own, OK?
So let me state the theorem.
And then we'll go over
a couple of examples
on how to use induction.
So let me recall from--
I think I just erased it.
N is the natural numbers.
And it has an
ordering, meaning--
so we'll precisely define
what ordering means.
But just in your head, this
means the usual thing--
1 is less than 2 is less
than 3 is less than 4.
So a property of
the natural numbers,
which will take as an axiom,
is the well-ordering property.
So an axiom is not
something you prove.
You assume this
about the objects
that you've defined or are
studying up to this point.
And so the statement
is if I take
a subset of natural
numbers, which is non-empty,
then S has a least element
or smallest element.
Now, what does this mean?
Let me write this
last statement out.
i.e.
There exists an x in S--
"st" I will often write,
meaning such that or so that--
such that x is less than or
equal to y for all y in S, OK?
So every non-empty subset
of the natural numbers
has a smallest element, OK?
We're going to take
that as an axiom,
as just a property of the
natural numbers, which
we'll assume.
Now, using this axiom,
we're going to prove--
it's not really often
you hear it called
as a principle of
mathematical induction,
but this will state it as a
theorem instead of a principle,
whatever a principle
is supposed to be.
So induction, so this
is due to Pascal.
Or at least in its first
rigorous formulation
is let Pn be a statement
depending on natural number n.
OK, so maybe we
have some equality
between two quantities that
involves a natural number n,
OK?
That could be our
statement P of n.
Now, we're going to assume--
so what are our hypotheses
about this statement?
What's our if?
Assume that this statement
satisfies two properties.
This first property is usually
referred to as a base case.
That is that P of 1 is true.
And the second property is
called the inductive step.
So this statement satisfies
the following property
that if you assume
P of m is true,
then you can prove that
P of m plus 1 is true.
So I have a statement
which satisfies
both of these properties, OK?
In particular, since I'm
assuming P of 1 is true,
by the second property,
P of 2 is true.
And then again by the second
property, P of 3 is true.
And then P of 4,
and then P of 5.
And so if you followed that
last line of reasoning,
this means you should
be able to guess
what the conclusion
of this theorem is.
Then P n is true for
all natural numbers, OK?
All right, so we're going to
use the well-ordering property
of the natural numbers
to prove this theorem
about the induction.
OK, so we have our assumptions.
I'm not going to--
although, I said over
there let B, C be
sets, I'm not going
to rewrite the assumptions that
we have about our statement
P. We're just going to
start trying to prove P of n
is true for all n.
So let me write our conclusion
slightly differently.
Let S be the set of all natural
numbers such that P of n
is not true.
So what I want to show is
that P of n is true for all n.
So that's equivalent
to saying we want
to show that S is empty, OK?
The set of natural numbers
where P of n is not true,
this is empty.
This is equivalent to saying
P of n is true for all n.
And the way we're
going to do this
is another staple of
mathematical proofs
is trying to prove this
by contradiction, OK?
So what does that mean?
Let me make a few comments
about what that means,
proof by a contradiction.
OK, so in a proof
by contradiction--
so this is-- what I'm
about to write down
is not part of the proof.
This is commentary not to
be included in the proof.
What does it mean
to say we're going
to prove S is equal to the
empty set by contradiction?
We're going to assume that
the statement we want to prove
is false.
Or not false, but
we want to assume
that the negation of the
statement we want to prove
is true and then arrive
at a false statement, OK?
So we want to assume--
this is what we're going to do.
We're going to
assume the negation
of the statement we
want to prove-- namely,
S is non-empty, OK?
And from this, we want to
derive a false statement, OK?
And so if we are to do-- if we
were able to do that, then--
let me just say, again, you
can check in the appendix
or you can just believe
me that the rules of logic
then say that our initial
assumption, that S was not
empty, is false
to begin with, OK?
So rules of logic, meaning
I cannot start from a true
assumption and derive, in
a logically consistent way,
a false statement, OK?
That is, if we believe that
the rules of logic we're using
are consistent, which that's a
little bit hairy to talk about.
But for our purposes
of our class,
you can believe me that
the rules of logic we use--
or at least accept
that the rules
of logic we're going to use
are consistent and sound.
OK, so back to
the proof at hand.
We have this set
of natural numbers
where the statement is not true.
We want to show it is empty.
We're going to do it by
contradiction, meaning
we're going to assume the
negation of the statement
we want to prove--
namely, S is non-empty.
And we're going to
derive a false statement
from that assumption, OK?
And by the rules of logic--
that means that our
initial assumption--
that S is non-empty--
is, in fact, false, OK?
All right, so towards
a contradiction,
suppose that S is non-empty, OK?
Now, we're going to use
the well-ordering property
of the natural numbers.
By the well-ordering property
of the natural numbers,
S has a least element, x, OK?
Now, what do we know about x?
So first off, x cannot be 1, OK?
S is a set where this
property does not hold.
x cannot be 1 because--
let me again rewrite this fact
that S has the least element.
Let me just reiterate that S has
a least element in the set, OK?
Now, x cannot be 1 because
we're assuming the base case,
meaning P of 1 is true.
So since P of 1 is true,
that means 1 is not
an S, which means x is not 1.
In particular, x must
be bigger than 1.
So x is some magical natural
number out there bigger than 1
that's the least
element of this set S.
OK, since x is the
least element of S--
so let me draw.
On the number line,
we have 1, 2, 3, 4.
Out there is some
magic point x, which
is the least element of S.
And the rest of the subset S
lies to the right of
this number x, right?
Because it's the
least element of S.
And therefore, x minus
1 cannot be in S.
So since x is the least element
of S and x minus 1 is less than
x, this means that x minus
1 is not in S. Otherwise,
it would be a smaller
element than x in S. So thus,
what does it mean
to not be in S?
It means that P of
x minus 1 is true.
By the definition of S,
this means P of x minus 1
is true, OK?
But by the second property we're
assuming about our statement P,
this means that the next guy
in line, x minus 1 plus 1,
is true, which is just x, which
means that x is not in S, OK?
So from the assumption--
so let me just recap.
From the assumption
that S is non-empty,
we've derived two facts.
1, x has the least element in
S. And that element is also not
in S.
So written out,
we've concluded there
exists a natural number which
is both in S and not in S.
And this is a false statement.
You cannot have an object and
member that's both in the set
and not in the set, OK?
And at the end of
contradiction arguments,
I'll usually put two
arrows hitting each other.
So that's a contradiction.
Therefore, our initial
assumption that S is non-empty
has to be false.
And therefore, S is
the empty set, OK?
So I encourage you to
go through that proof
a little slowly because
maybe you got turned around
by taking the complements
or the general scheme of how
a proof by contradiction works.
But don't spend too much time
on it because, as I've said,
this theorem itself and its
proof are not the thing we're
really interested in.
Or at least, it's not
the most interesting.
It's more of a tool
that we'll use to prove
more interesting statements.
OK, so how do we actually
use this theorem, induction,
to prove other statements?
So I guess I should
include this here.
This falls under the
umbrella of logic,
meaning we're going
to approve previous--
we're going to use
previous statements we've
proven to prove new statements.
But anyway, so how do we
use induction in practice?
So if we want to
prove some statement--
for all n, Pn is true--
in the print then, this
theorem about induction--
this theorem of
induction-- tells us
we just have to
do two things, OK?
We have to prove the base case.
And this is usually easy.
You just stick the number
1 into the statement
that you want to prove.
And that's the end of the story.
And the second step is usually--
or the second thing
we have to prove
is the more involved
part, which is
we have to prove that the
statement that if PM is true,
then P of m plus 1 is true, OK?
If we want to do a
proof by induction,
there's two smaller
proofs we have to do.
First, we have to
prove P of 1 is true.
And then we have to
prove this statement.
If P of m, then P of m plus 1.
So again, this is usually
referred to as the base case.
This is the inductive step.
So let's try and
actually do this.
All right, so-- so another
question I get at the beginning
of a course, especially
about proofs--
because there's a lot of
uncertainty about what you
can assume is true, what
can you use, what can you
not use, right now,
at this point, you
can use whatever
you know about any
of the algebraic properties,
you know about the real numbers,
the rational numbers--
and by algebraic properties,
I mean if a plus b equals
c, then a plus b times
d equals c times d--
and what you know
about inequalities.
So we're going to go much
more in depth into ordering,
which is what
inequality is a part of.
But you can use
all the properties
you know about solving
inequalities or manipulating
inequalities, meaning if I
have one number is less than
or equal to another number,
then when I multiply
both sides by a
positive number, that
doesn't change the inequality.
So you can use all of
these algebraic properties
of rationals and real
numbers from here on out.
I mean, so we're going to be
proving things about calculus.
So you certainly cannot use
anything about continuity,
differentiation, or
anything like that.
But for now, you can use all the
algebraic properties you know.
So the first statement
we're going to try and prove
using induction is the statement
that for all c not equal
to 1, for all n, a
natural number, 1
plus c plus c squared plus c to
the n equals 1 minus c to the n
plus 1 over 1 minus c, OK?
So this here is our
statement P of n.
It depends on the
natural number n, OK?
So we're going to do this by
induction, which means we're
going to do those two things.
We're going to prove
the base case, P of 1,
which I said is easy.
And then we're going to
prove the second case,
the second property, the
inductive step, which
is a little more involved,
but not so much involved,
at least in the beginning.
So let me call this
inequality star.
We're going to prove
star by induction.
So first, we will
do the base case.
And like I said, the
base case is usually you
just plug in n equals 1 and
verify that P of n is true.
And that's what we do.
1 plus c to the 1, which is the
left-hand side, does, in fact,
equal 1 minus c to the 1 plus
1 over 1 minus c because this
right-hand side--
1 minus c squared is 1
minus c times 1 plus c--
the 1 minus c's cancel.
And so the base case
is proven, all right?
Now, we do the
inductive step, OK?
So we're going to assume that
star holds for n equals m
So we're going to assume P of m.
So assume that 1 plus
c plus c to the m
equals 1 minus c
over 1 minus c, OK?
Now, we want to show--
again, let's write out what we
want to do, what's our plan.
We want to prove that this
equality, that this line
star holds for n
equals m plus 1, OK?
So again, what I
wrote here, this
is basically star
for n equals m, OK?
And let me call this
second inequality--
the second equality 2 star.
So this is my assumption
for m, n equals m.
OK, so let's take the left side
for n equals m plus 1 and see
if we cannot massage it to
get the right-hand side for--
I should say the right-hand
side for n equals m plus 1.
So here is the calculation part.
So we have 1 plus c plus c to
the m plus c to the m plus 1.
This is the m plus 1 case of
the left-hand side of star,
which we want to
show is to the--
is equal to the n equals n plus
1 case of the right-hand side.
Now, this is equal to--
now, we already know what this
is equal to by our assumption.
This is by the second
star there, which
is what we're assuming is true.
This is equal to 1
minus c n plus 1 over 1
minus c plus cm plus 1.
And so now, we just do
a little bit of algebra.
This is equal to
1 over 1 minus c
m plus 1 plus c m plus 1 minus
c m plus 2 over 1 minus c.
Those cancel and I'm left with
1 minus c to the m plus 2.
And I'll write it just so that
you can see this is really
the m plus 1 case, all right?
So again, we arrived
at this first step
by our assumption, the
second starred equation, OK?
So thus, star holds
for n equals m plus 1.
So by induction-- or really,
I should say the theorem
of induction that we proved--
our equality between those two
objects, or two expressions,
is valid for all n, OK?
OK.
OK, so let's do one more
example of using induction.
So let's prove if C is
a real number bigger
than or equal to minus
1, then for all n,
a natural number,
1 plus c to the n
is bigger than or equal
to 1 plus n times c, OK?
All right, so we're going to
do this by induction again.
That means we need to
prove the base case
and we need to do
the inductive step.
So base case, as always, will--
so this is just right here.
We're going to do
this by induction.
So as you can see,
the base case is,
again, n equals 1 is clear
just by looking at it.
1 plus c to the 1, in fact,
equals 1 plus 1 times c.
So it's certainly bigger than
or equal to 1 plus n times c.
So I think that's the last
stars I'll use for this lecture.
So our statement, our
inequality star star star,
holds for n equals 1.
All right, so that's
our base case.
Now, we're going to assume
that this inequality holds
for n equals m and
try to prove that it
holds for n equals m plus 1.
So we're assuming
this when n equals m.
So 1 plus c to the m is bigger
than or equal to 1 plus m times
c.
And we want to prove
this inequality with n
equal to m plus 1.
And we're just
assuming this guy, OK?
So I want to get the statement
for n equals m plus 1.
One way to do that
is this left side.
I want to get--
let's look at the n
equals m plus 1 side
and see what we can do with it.
So again, this is a
calculation part and logic.
So we have 1 plus
c to the m plus 1.
So that's the n equals
m plus 1 side of this.
This is equal to 1 plus c
times 1 plus c to the m.
Now, we're assuming,
again, this inequality.
This is the n equals m case.
So we can use it.
So we're assuming it.
We use it.
And since C is bigger than
or equal to minus 1, 1 plus C
is non-negative.
So this thing is bigger
than or equal to this thing.
So if I multiply both
sides by 1 plus c,
I preserve the inequality.
So this is bigger than or
equal to 1 plus mc, OK?
Again, this just follows from
essentially the assumption
multiplied through
by 1 plus c, OK?
So now, I'm going
to finagle this.
So let me just--
I'm not doing anything
different here.
I'm just going to
rewrite this over
here so that I can have
a chain of inequality.
So I have 1 plus c to the m plus
1 is greater than or equal to 1
plus c 1 plus mc.
All right, so now, this is
bigger than or equal to this.
And this here-- so
when I write equal,
I do not mean that
this left side is now
equal to what I'm
about to write here.
That means the previous thing on
here is equal to what I'm about
to write here, OK/ this is a
typical fashion and writing
down inequalities--
or I guess, practice.
So this is equal to 1--
so just doing the algebra--
m plus 1 times c plus
m times c squared, OK?
Now, this part is exactly the
n equals m plus 1 side of this.
And I have a little room
to give because now this
is plus something
that's non-negative.
So let me just
rewrite this again.
This means that 1
plus c to the m plus 1
is greater than or
equal to 1 plus--
so again, I'm kind of
writing a lot here.
I will stop writing as
much as the course goes on.
But I encourage you,
especially in the beginning,
to write all the
steps and logic, OK?
So again, I'm not
rewriting anything.
I'm just summarizing
what I've done here.
Now, this right-hand side--
so I have this as bigger than
or equal to this.
And this right-hand
side, since I
have a number plus
something non-negative,
m times c squared--
m's a natural number.
This is bigger than or
equal to 1 m plus 1 times c.
Thus, 1 plus c to the m plus
1 is greater than or equal to,
which is the n
equals n plus 1 case.
So by induction, this inequality
triple star holds for all n.
All right.